how's it going bros my name is hell is
that supposed to me I'm 9 anyway so
welcome back to South Park unfortunately
I can't show more of the story until the
actual game is released which is
perfectly understandable but then I was
allowed to do some side quests and I
want to cover this game as much as
possible I just love playing it so I
figured now it's the perfect time to
actually do the side quest that's sync
yeah the game's it is 4th of March by
the way so I got a lot of questions
about it
so that's where we can continue but for
now let's do some tag quest because they
seem they seem pretty awesome to me at
least uh alright yeah when the nation's
youth run around in Dungeon clothes
playing the games of Satan young man if
you really want power there's only one
thing you must do find Jesus find him
and when you do return to me all right
so we have another side quest fine Jesus
sounds fun we're literally gonna find
Jesus I guess you know you really there
we are at the church this is gonna be a
controversial episode yeah damn it
how about yes teehee what the hell you
found me tee hee hee next time finding
me won't be so easy
[Music]
really baby why are we gonna find Jesus
next I can't wait to see I need to talk
to him right
do not despair for many find Jesus only
to lose him later but the soul that does
not abandon it search will surely be
rewarded with his company remember that
god damn it could you just tell me what
is fine Jesus one more time okay let's
find him one more time where I could
Jesus be if I were Jesus where would I
be in the church again why am I doing
this
alright it's not so easy this time huh
alright well let's let's look everywhere
to make sure we can actually find him I
like the purple decoration
I like the episode where Kyle's can't
get a hemorrhoid ants and Cartman gets
like millions of dollar Oh God I hear
you you know
maybe if we turn up the lights we can
trick them out or something Jay says
come on come out I know you're there
Debbie so annoying Tonya know Dave says
I'm touching your shirt faithful in CD
The Hollywood be here Saint Peter I will
sell him so hard
all right knock it off Jesus run around
town I'm blockin for Jesus Jason Jason
oh here we go
I don't know I can move this how about
now I found Jesus well God my son I hope
you didn't peek remember I will always
be at the side of those who have found
me you can call me once per day with
this but I can't help against bosses
they're scary come find me again for
another that's called the actually get
something from doing the sacrifice oh my
god jesus is my friend on Facebook I got
a new message from priest what the hell
is he wanting I'm glad that you found
Christ my son yeah ever vigilant for he
may be found in the unluckiest places
times me I found him in my chimney once
if he's talking about Santa Claus Jesus
like this apparently that's great all
right so what's next quest we got stop
it alright fine I'll go in I never
actually been in a cinema what that [ __ ]
I want to see that movie I want to see
that movie also interesting
[Music]
well I'm glad we did that
what's in here oh the episode with the
right coming out of his [ __ ] isn't
what I like a deficit helped me there
was a mixup at the post office
and they accidentally gave me a package
for miss Cartman any chance you can go
to the post office and pick up mine
while I drop this one by her house I
guess miss Cartman I like to shop at the
same places haha
wonder why ha ha mr. slave's package
dead reason invited from post obvious he
said it would be bouncing around by or
vibrating it's probably a bouncing
vibrator ball vibrating ball I have on
toe it's in my pants
alright where's the post office I never
been there I think
oh yeah it's here right yeah post office
did it do
there we are that machine hey butters
sweet kid
Ernest I need it now that's [ __ ]
nasty man I'll just take it I guess it's
a whole lot better now here if you ever
need my help use this I can't help with
any tough fights though I don't want to
get a phizzer
come back and find me if you want to
call me again but give it a day
I go to a lot of parties wonderful what
I got a whip this is Martha Stewart
again I really love this game man I wish
I could continue with this story but
cyclists are ok for now I guess this is
gonna [ __ ] you up
I'm gonna mess you up dude
okay let's summon Jesus to attack him
[Music]
Jesus is awesome that's funny you can't
expect me to pat you on the back just
because you've made a few friends as
soon as you have a lot of friends then
I'll be proud shitty parents unlocked
let's check our room
oh no don't it what come on no what
happens if I don't succeed imperfect
like a half poop or God's pooping so
hard man come on poop you [ __ ]
up
it means you get a free wish without it
I don't get anything oh yeah I do
I got a [ __ ] now yes nice nice nice
let's take a shower
that's good very refreshing Thank You
Ernest throw this chart at your enemies
to gross them out ah Watson
that's pretty it's pretty practical
genius actually I got it
gotta hand it to myself oh yeah let's
check out butters house but it really is
a very sweet boy I hope you'll treat him
as you would a normal child oh this must
be the new kid yeah good for you
you Facebook me right away if butters
does something he should be grounded
fall for butters
youth of Sweden in his name let's see
what kind of [ __ ] we can find his
bedroom [ __ ] television man oh why
don't we got here minions they help me
put a society cares Larry key that was I
oh c'mon nice the poopy the poop equals
boobs
ha ha ha ha ha ha check his closet for
all the references what are we the
answers to have man tequila first of
what what am i but Imaginationland
collection set as also one of my
favorite episodes imagination
imagination imagination imagination aim
had your new sean imagination imagine
new new message what the hell I want you
to know that very sorry about butters
just in general that's a great dad isn't
it alright let's make an investment at
the bank actually that would be fun
don't forget where you do all that tom
is like my favorite character thanks for
checking
welcome to the Vegas dad park would you
like to invest money with us today
charlie invest 25 move young man in a
boat first step towards your financial
future
well thanks take that money and employ
significant leverage using
computer-assisted high frequency trading
and index fund rebalancing to buy ahead
of certain stock movements and it's got
welcome to the biggest come on he'd come
back when you have some money to invest
well I'm glad I spent that time
oh [ __ ] it scared me goddamn homazooma
uh he has a rat to fight with him it's
quite impressive all right someone
rawhide whip go by the power of a gay
ooh this could be kind of fun is he
gonna
[Music]
[Laughter]
pretty cool I guess that is made a
holder alright so this is a little bit
weird episode I wanted to do before you
brother since you wanted to see more
South Park but like I said in the
beginning I'll see you on March 4 when
the game is released hopefully it will
also watch me play it and not displayed
yourself bother than I had maybe like
I'm enjoying watching breaths I really
do appreciate it I hit the sky cover
today see brothers in next one love you
boys
[Music]
you